so as far as this game is concerned like
I said the basic
[Music]
starting 14 seconds starred in 10
seconds
[Music]
okay
maybe season of their teammates
like that
[Music]
yeah you can see it that's how to go wow
also it's all it's all procedural yes oh
wow how do you know that
are they
all right there you go in
so again the world is entirely
procedurally generated
I get Trixie
and again see man oh yeah they're all
over there see man
always beef was going down
buzzer early okay all right attic
right this oh oh yeah oh they were
nice
no they are fast
he's running out that he had a gonna
build Thursday
nice party or is it down state so it
in addition to you
so yeah what's that yellow that
indicated a yellow oh gosh
gotta go
yeah about that
engines are open runners will be
revealed in a second
go their whole little fist thing about
so it's kind like a melee attack okay
got it
get a get them at it
first time not that bad that's the first
bet
okay so even between rounds Wow nice so
that that way it is like that you can't
get reliant on which kind of forces
activity I put a unique I've never seen
a game procedurally generate the map
between rounds that's very unique
Oh
you
what does that cue button do what does
that do
okay
they're so fast they're so fast
[Laughter]
also he does have a sprint
nice I didn't get good man go to a
[Music]
there's one over there too
all I got in it
we are together
you can just
that he's coming he's coming down there
you go
nice get it
Radek man you'll end up spider-man or
like that component boy bouncing noises
[Music]
so that aim row there we go
Anakin ability
difficult gain chakra
nice you get the hang of it now he's
getting better now you got better down
yeah you getting better now it's
starting to get very intuitive
now will there ever be like more class
types or for now it's is going to be
limited intellect of the other runners
the hunters out of it I understand we
might be revealed later
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay man
we like it man we've been so what when
any ideas upon a release or when a might
release dude I'm a podcaster pleasure
absolutely
you